it's not often that on my show that I
get to speak to a French citizen and get
their perspective what is your take on
our president-elect Wow elect Trump what
do you what's your opinion I when I
moved here to America I was right in the
middle of the campaign and I kept
hearing America great again great again
let's make America let's make America
and I was like if it's not that great
they should have told us before we move
because I think it's great and I love
America yeah but I know I was like maybe
they should put a people in embassies
American embassies all around the world
and it would you know warn people when
you come to apply for a visa did we tell
you you know I know you want to move to
America but just so you know no it's not
that you know we're working on it bring
it back it's like it's a restaurant or
something yeah tell you not right now
come back maybe it's like when you go
get shopping and that the salesman is
like I should not tell you but it's
gonna be on sale come back come back now
I'm talking about you being French since
you were born in Morocco I was born in
Morocco this is my home country they're
watching this show right now in
Casablanca and Morocco say hi - uh yeah
my home city Casablanca
okay that's it you just did it know
people are like where is that no they
all know the movie Casablanca okay yeah
they all think it's a place where people
just are all in black and white and
smoke cigarettes I know what it was
exactly
you